there's a wacky and ridiculous headline
that appeared on screen on fox news
that's obviously really dumb but it's
actually also a serious thing that I
want to talk about which with you which
is the total misunderstanding of Latin
America that exists these lower-third
images matter that show up at the bottom
when you tune in to MSNBC or CNN or Fox
News even before you listen to what's
being said to figure out what the topic
is to see if you're interested you often
will just read what's at the bottom of
the screen the lower third as it's often
called um and when Donald Trump over the
weekend announced that he was going to
be cutting aid to three Latin American
countries El Salvador Guatemala and
Honduras these are three countries right
this is not Mexico these are three other
countries FoxNews erroneously
inadvertently wrote the headline that
Donald Trump cuts aid to three Mexican
countries that's what it said on screen
Trump cuts US aid to three Mexican
countries so yes hahaha they don't know
geography they don't know about Latin
America these are countries that many
people come to the u.s. from so they are
Mexico through Mexico so they are
Mexican countries fine it's nonsense and
Fox News apologized for it and then they
corrected it but there's actually a
really deep thing that I want to talk
about and this is the perfect
opportunity to talk about it and there's
a sort of geopolitical side and then
there's a personal side which I'll tell
you about this
so first the geopolitical lots of
Americans don't know about all of these
Latin American countries when they think
about immigration they sort of imagine
people from this mess of countries below
Mexico it's people who are basically
just like Mexicans they speak Spanish
who most importantly are trying to
invade the United States through the
southern border so it doesn't really
matter if they're coming from Guatemala
or Honduras or Costa Rica Panama or
Venezuela or wherever and of course
they're only coming from some of these
countries in any significant numbers in
the same way that they don't care to
know or understand the differences
between like single-payer versus
medicare-for-all versus a nationalized
healthcare system it's just it's
communism in the minds of many people
they don't care or know the differences
between what's happening in Mexico
versus what's happening in Honduras
versus Guatemala or the fact that these
countries have different indigenous
groups each of whom have different
cultures and different histories and
very often speak different languages in
addition to Spanish and they definitely
have no idea that the United States
relationships to these countries in the
last hundred years has been drastically
different if you consider the US history
in Nicaragua for example to the US
history with Costa Rica and Mexico as an
example there is very little in common
other than yeah a bunch of the people in
these countries speak Spanish so in a
sense the stupid-head line of Trump is
cutting aid to three Mexican countries
it's more accurate than you can imagine
in terms of the worldview that exists
for many of these right-wingers and
Trump Asst so that's on the geopolitical
side now on the personal individual sort
of identity politics I'd even relatively
educated people are very confused about
Latin America I have this funny anecdote
where someone I know has family has
cousins who live in a rural conservative
part of the United States and there was
a point in time where where the the the
cousins were sort of confused they've
somehow heard I David speaks Spanish oh
I speak Spanish yeah David speak Spanish
he's from Argentina and they said oh
he's Mexican wait wait he speaks Spanish
he's Mexican no he's from Argentina
that's a different country it's in South
America not in Central America lots of
countries speak Spanish Mexican is a
nationality oh but isn't David's white
right yet that's right he is white and
his ethnicity is you know Ashkenazi
Jewish but you can be from any country
and speak any language and then it was
wait there are Jews in Mexico and the
answer is of course there are Jews in
Mexico but David's not from Mexico Dave
is from Argentina so the stupid headline
is sadly I wish it weren't the case I
wish we could just laugh it off as some
dumb thing on Fox News it actually is a
really good opportunity to point out
there are a lot of understandings out
there about Latin America and in the
same way that many people in the West
see that jumble of countries when you
look at a map of Africa as not
particularly distinct and only when you
actually inform yourself do you realize
about countries that where French is
spoken that are very distinct from other
parts of Africa northern and southern
Africa West Africa and all of these
different conflicts and and sort of
internal politics there's a very similar
sort of perspective with Latin and South
America and it doesn't make any sense
and this stupid headline on Fox News as
dumb as it is actually is sort of
opening the door to a lot of that so I'm
kind of glad to have the opportunity to
discuss it because I don't know how else
I would kind of randomly bring it up but
anyway Fox News they apologized and who
knows who they blamed it doesn't even
matter at this point some kind of error
in the control room as they often say
but that is actually the perspective of
many people when they hear that these
three countries are no longer getting
aid from the United States what they
imagine is these are all countries where
people just come in over the us-mexico
border
let's cut aid to all of them until they
do what we want and what that is never
exactly clear when you hear Trump say
they're not even doing anything for us
make sure you're following the show on
Instagram at David Pakman show we will
take a quick break next I will be joined
by David Farris and we will talk about
our Democrats fighting dirty to use the
term that he used in terms of
encouraging how Democrats should behave
last time he was on are they fighting
dirty yet or are they not
David Farris joins me next today's
program brought to you in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman Blinky's is a great
service that i use all the time what
they do is they take thousands of the
most popular non-fiction books including
the newest bestsellers they condense
them into 15-minute audiobooks that you
can listen to and you still get the most
crucial information and insights from
each book and I've listened to a ton of
books on blink as' I recently checked
out
soccer na mcc's
Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book of BS jobs by David
Graeber which I listened to on blinka
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I'm putting a link in the
video description and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa k ma n